où la couleur de notre peau, donne non seulement une première impression,
mais aussi une impression qui perdure.
Je suis née dans une famille de toutes les couleurs.
Mon père est le fils d'une domestique
dont il a hérité un teint très foncé.
Il a été adopté par ces gens que je considère comme mes grands-parents.
La matriarche, ma grand-mère,
a une peau de porcelaine et des cheveux comme du coton.
Mon grand-père avait un teint qui se situait quelque part entre le yaourt
à la vanille et le yaourt à la fraise, comme mon oncle et mon cousin.
Avec sa peau couleur cannelle, ma mère est la fille d'une brésilienne,
avec des nuances de noisettes et de miel,
et d'un homme à la peau café au lait,
mais principalement couleur café.
Elle a deux sœurs.
L'une a le teint d'une cacahuète grillée
et l'autre,
adoptée elle aussi,
a plutôt le teint beige,
comme une crêpe.
(Rires)
Ayant grandi dans cette famille, la couleur de peau
n'a jamais été un élément important pour moi.
Cependant, à l'extérieur, les choses étaient différentes.
La couleur de peau avait bien d'autres significations.
Je me souviens de mon premier cours de dessin à l'école
comme d'un déluge de sentiments contradictoires.
C'était passionnant et artistique
mais je n'ai jamais compris l'unique crayon de couleur chair.
J'étais faite de chair mais je n'étais pas rose.
Ma peau était brune et les gens disaient que j'étais noire.
J'avais sept ans et tout un fatras de couleurs dans ma tête.
Plus tard,
lorsque j'emmenais mon cousin à l'école,
on me prenait généralement pour la nounou.
Si je donnais un coup de main en cuisine lors d'une fête chez un ami,
les gens pensaient que j'étais la servante.
On m'a même prise pour une prostituée,
simplement parce que je marchais seule sur la plage avec des amis européens.
Et à maintes reprises, lorsque
je rendais visite à ma grand-mère ou à des amis dans des bâtiments huppés,
on me demandait de ne pas utiliser l'ascenseur principal.
Parce que, en fin de compte,
avec cette couleur et ces cheveux,
je n'étais pas à ma place dans certains endroits.
D'une certaine manière,
je m'y suis habituée et j'en ai même accepté une partie.
Cependant, quelque chose en moi voulait se révolter et se battre.
Des années plus tard, j'ai épousé un Espagnol.
Mais pas n'importe quel Espagnol.
J'en ai choisi un avec la peau qui prend une couleur de homard au soleil.
(Rires)
Dès lors, une nouvelle question commençait à me tarauder.
Quelle sera la couleur de nos enfants ?
Comme vous pouvez le comprendre, c'était la dernière de mes préoccupations.
Mais en y réfléchissant,
avec mes antécédents,
mon histoire personnelle m'a amenée à cet exercice intime de photographie.
Et c'est comme ça qu'Humanae est né.
Humanae est une quête visant à mettre en lumière nos vraies couleurs,
plutôt que les clichés
blanc, rouge, noir ou jaune associés à la race.
C'est une sorte de jeu avec pour but d'interroger nos codes.
C'est un projet en cours. D'une histoire personnelle à une histoire universelle.
Je prends les sujets en photo sur un fond blanc.
Ensuite, j'extrais de leur nez un carré de 11 pixels,
je peins le fond de cette couleur et
je cherche à quelle couleur ça correspond dans la palette industrielle Pantone.
J'ai commencé avec ma famille et des amis,
puis de plus en plus de gens se sont joints à cette aventure,
grâce à des annonces postées sur les réseaux sociaux.
Je pensais que l'endroit idéal pour exposer mon travail serait Internet
puisque je voulais que ce concept soit ouvert à tous,
que tout le monde puisse le partager en ligne et dans les esprits.
C'était le début de l'effet boule de neige.
Le projet a eu un très bon accueil.
Avec des invitations,
des expositions, en dur,
dans des galeries et des musées...
Le projet avance.
Parmi tout ça, ce que je préfère
c'est lorsque Humanae occupe l'espace public
et descend dans les rues,
qu'il crée un débat public et
engendre un sentiment d'appartenance.
J'ai tiré le portrait de plus de 3000 personnes,
dans 13 pays différents
et 19 villes différentes à travers le monde.
Juste pour vous donner une idée,
cela va de quelqu'un qui est dans le classement Forbes
à des réfugiés qui ont traversé la Méditerranée en bateau.
À Paris, du siège de l'UNESCO à un refuge pour sans-abris.
Et des élèves que ce soit en Suisse ou dans les favelas de Rio de Janeiro.
Toutes sortes de croyances,
de genres,
ou de handicaps physiques.
Du nouveau-né jusqu'au malade en phase terminale.
Tous ensemble, nous avons construit Humanae.
Ces portraits nous font réfléchir à la façon dont nous percevons les autres.
Quand la science moderne remet en cause le concept de race,
qu'est-ce que cela signifie pour nous d'être noir, blanc, jaune, rouge ?
Est-ce les yeux, le nez, la bouche, les cheveux ?
Ou bien est-ce que cela a à voir avec notre origine,
notre nationalité
ou notre compte en banque ?
Cet exercice personnel s'est avéré être une découverte.
J'ai soudain pris conscience que Humanae était utile pour beaucoup de gens.
C'est une espèce de miroir
pour ceux qui ne se considèrent pas représentés par une quelconque étiquette.
C'était incroyable
quand les gens ont commencé à partager leurs avis sur le projet avec moi.
J'en ai des centaines
et je vais les partager avec vous.
Une mère de 11 ans...
La mère d'une fillette de 11 ans m'a écrit :
« C'est un très bon outil pour l'aider à prendre de l'assurance,
après qu'une de ses copines,
le weekend dernier, lui a dit qu'elle n'était pas à sa place ici
et qu'elle ne devrait pas être autorisée à vivre en Norvège.
Votre travail occupe une place très particulière dans mon cœur
et est très important pour moi. »
Une femme a posté son portrait sur Facebook et a écrit :
« Toute ma vie,
dans le monde entier, les gens n'arrivaient pas à me mettre dans
un groupe, un stéréotype,
une case.
Peut-être que nous devrions arrêter.
Au lieu de mettre les individus dans une case, nous devrions leur demander :
"Comment vous qualifieriez-vous ?".
Je répondrais :
"Bonjour. Je m'appelle Massiel.
Je suis dominico-hollandaise,
j'ai grandi dans une famille mixte
et je suis une femme bisexuelle" ».
Outre ces réactions inattendues et touchantes,
Humanae a trouvé une nouvelle vie dans une grande variété de domaines.
Pour vous donner quelques exemples,
les illustrateurs et les étudiants en art
l'utilisent comme référence pour leurs croquis et leurs études.
C'est une collection de visages.
Les chercheurs en anthropologie,
en physique et en neuroscience
utilisent Humanae avec des approches scientifiques
aussi variées que l'ethnologie,
l'optophysiologie,
la reconnaissance faciale ou
la maladie d'Alzheimer.
L'un des retentissements les plus importants de la série,
c'est lorsque Humanae a été choisie pour la couverture de Foreign Affairs,
une revue politique des plus pertinentes.
À propos d'affaires étrangères,
j'ai trouvé le parfait ambassadeur pour mon projet...
Les enseignants.
Ils utilisent Humanae à des fins éducatives.
Leur enthousiasme m'a poussé à retourner en classe de dessin,
mais cette fois-ci en tant qu'enseignante.
Mes étudiants,
adultes et enfants,
peignent leur autoportrait,
dans le but de découvrir leur couleur personnelle.
Grâce à la photographie,
je me rends compte que je peux inciter les gens à communiquer.
À titre personnel,
moi, Angélica,
à chaque fois que je prends une photo,
j'ai l'impression d'être face à mon thérapeute.
Toute la frustration, la peur et la solitude,
que j'ai pu ressentir,
se transforment en amour.
Le dernier pays...
Le dernier pays au monde à avoir aboli l'esclavage
est le pays où je suis née :
le Brésil.
Nous devons continuer à nous battre afin d'abolir les discriminations.
Cela reste une pratique courante dans le monde entier,
qui ne disparaîtra pas d'elle-même.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)